hey everyone let's get started so um
let's see plan for today is we'll go
over the rest of ICA independent
component analysis and in particular
talk about CDF's cumulative distribution
functions and then um
all right so plan is a we'll go over the
rest of ICA independent components
analysis and we'll talk a bit about CDF
cumulative distribution functions and
then derive the ISEE model and in the
second half of today we'll start on the
final of the four major topics of the
cost which is reinforcement learning we
talk about MDPs or Marvel teacher
processes
so to recap briefly we had you remember
the overlapping voices demo so we said
that in the I see a problem dependent
components now this problem we're seeing
we have sources s which are are n if you
have n speakers so for example if this
is speaker ones audio then at time T s
you know superscript parenthesis T
subscript 1 is the sound emitted by
speaker 1 at time T as I've seen all
right make that go a little bit and
we're using sometimes I to index
training examples and so the training
examples sweep over time and sometimes
usually I use I sometimes I use T I
guess in the case where the different
examples come from different points in
time in your recording and what your
microphones record is X I equals a of s
I so just for now let's say you have two
speakers and two microphones in which
case a will be a 2 by 2 matrix and home
or problem your face because in five
microphones in which case a will be a
five by five matrix what's helped later
about what happens is the numbers
because in microphones is not the same
and the goal is to find a matrix W which
should hopefully be a inverse so that si
is w times X recover the original
sources and we're going to use these W 1
up to WN
represent the rows of this matrix w oh
yes you're right thank you
so last time we had all right just
remember this is a picture the cocktail
party problem and last time I showed
these pictures about you know why why is
ICA even possible right given two
overlapping voices how is even possible
to separate them out how is there enough
information to know you know what are
the two overlapping voices and so one
picture we saw was this one where if s1
and s2 are uniform between minus 1 and
plus 1 then the distribution of data
will look like this if you pass this
data through the mixing matrix a then
your observations now the axes have
changed X 1 and X 2 may look like this
and your job is a finding unmixing
matrix W that map's this data back to
the square ok now this example is
possible because the examples because
the sources s-one and s-two were
distributed uniformly between minus 1
and plus 1 it turns out human voices you
know the recordings per moment in time I
not distributed uniform between minus 1
and plus 1 and it turns out that dumped
if the data was Gaussian then ICA is
actually not possible
here's what I mean let's say that so the
uniform distribution is a highly non
Gaussian distribution right uniformly
mine's one plus one you know this is not
Gaussian and that that makes I see
possible
what if s1 and s2 came from Gaussian
densities right if that were the case
then this distribution s1 and s2 would
be rotationally symmetric and so there'd
be a rotational ambiguity right any axis
could be s 1 and s 2 you can't map you
know this type of parallelogram back to
this square
right so so you can't so if I think in
this parallelogram you can sort of read
off you know there may be one axis
should look like that
sorry I'm joining with Mouse not doing
very well well second axis should maybe
look like that right and by by inverting
that you can get the data back to the
square but in the case of the data look
like this then you actually don't know
because maybe this should be s 1 and
that should be s 2 right but so there's
this rotational ambiguity because the
Gaussian distribution is rotationally
symmetric of s 1 and s 2 are standard
Gaussian then then this distribution is
rotation symmetric and you don't have
enough information to recover the
directions that correspond to the
original sources
ok so it turns out that there is some
ambiguity and the output of ICA in
particular last time we talked about two
sources of ambiguity you don't know
which is speaker 1 at which the speaker
2 right you don't know which one to
number speaker 1 which on the numbers
because you and you might take this data
and flip it horizontally reflect this
you know on the name s 1 goes to
negative s 1 or reflect this on the
vertical axis we don't know this
positive s 2 and negative s 2 and in the
case of this example where s 1 s 2 a
uniform minus 1 plus 1 those are the
only sources of ambiguity but the data
was Gaussian that the additional
rotation on vacuity which actually in
part which actually makes it impossible
to separate out the sources ok so it
turns out that
so it turns out that the Gaussian
density is the only distribution that is
rotationally symmetric if s1 and s2 are
independent and the distribution is
rotationally symmetric meaning that the
distribution has sort of circular
contours then it then it then it must be
a Gaussian density and so there is a
theorem which just stated formally that
I see is possible only if your data is
not Gaussian right but but so once your
data is not Gaussian then it is possible
to recover the independent sources okay
I'm just taking that informally so let's
see so what I'd like to do is develop
the ICA algorithm assuming that the data
is non Gaussian okay now in order to
divert the ICA model we need to figure
out what is the density of s right and
I'm going to use P subscript s you know
of the of the random variable s to
represent the density of s an equivalent
way to represent the probability of the
density of continuous random variables
virus CDF which stands for cumulative
distribution functions and the
cumulative distribution function of a
random variable f of s in probability is
defined as the chance that the random
variable is less than that value so I
guess notation has been inconsistent
sorry but this is capital S I'm using to
denote the random variable and this is
some constant right and it's that same
constants is that lowercase s okay and
so for example if
this is the PDF of random variable s may
be of a Gaussian right the CDF is a
function that increases from 0 to 1
where the height of a CDF at a certain
point is the probability so if you take
the curves the same point so the height
of a CDF at a certain point lowercase s
is the probability that the random
variable takes on the value equal to
this value or lower which means that the
height of this function is equal to you
know the probability mass the area under
the curve of your PDF over to the left
at that point okay so that's a know some
sometimes this some problem in
statistics courses teach this concept in
some Jones I guess but there so there's
a mapping between the PDS and the CDF of
a function of a continuous random
variable and the relation between the
PDF and the CDF is that the density is
equal to the first derivative right F
prime so if you take the derivative of
the CDF then you should recover the PDF
ok but so I think in order to specify
you know some random variable we could
either specify the PDF right the
probably density function or you could
specify the CDF which is just no less
tell me what's the chance of the random
variable taking on any value less than
any particular value s and by taking the
derivative this you can always recover
the PDF and by integrating this you can
always go to the senior ok and so what
we're going to do in ICA is instead of
specifying a PDF for how speakers voices
sound we're instead going to specify a
CDF and we have to choose as India
that is not the Gaussian density CDF
because we have assumed that the data is
non Gaussian and and the CDF you know is
a function that always goes from right
zero to one okay so
all right so we'll specify so in a
little bit we'll specify some CDF for
the density of the sources of what human
voices sound like let's say and if you
differentiate this you will get the PDF
or the density is equal to that now um
we're going to derive a massive likely
estimation algorithm in a minute but our
model is that X is equal to a s which is
equal to I guess W inverse of s and s is
equal to WX right so that that's that's
the model and in order to derive a
maximum likelihood estimate for the
parameters when you have so this is
going to be the density X so this is a
relationship between this is
relationship between X and s X is equal
to a s equals W inverse s and has to
equal to WX right so this is a model and
what I'd like to do is let's say you
know what's the density of s what is the
density of X if X is computed as the
matrix a times s so one step that's
tempting to take is to just say well s
is equal to W times X so the probability
of X is just equal to the probability of
s taking on the certain value right so
so I mean this is s and so the
probability of seeing a certain value of
x is equal to the probability of s
taking on that corresponding value
because assuming W is an invertible
matrix
is one-to-one mapping between X and s so
to find it probably FX just find a pair
of s and compute a corresponding
probability it turns out this is this is
incorrect and this works were probably
mask functions but discreet party
distributions that take on discrete
values but this is actually incorrect
for continuous probability densities so
let me let me um show an illustration
and go back to derive what is a correct
way of computing the density of X oh and
we'll want a density of X because when
you get the training set you only get to
observe X and so for finding a master of
like ledesma parameters you need to know
what's the density of X you come and you
know choose the parameters choose the
parameters W the maximizing likelihood
so that's what we want to compute the
density of X but um let's let's use a
simple example let's say the density of
s is indicator SS between 0 and 1 okay
so this is SS distribution uniform from
0 to 1 and let's say X is equal to 2
times s sitting on notation is equal to
2 W is equal to 1/2 this is a N equals 1
one dimensional example so this is a
density of s right uniform distribution
from 0 to 1 and if X is equal to 2 times
s then this seems like X should be equal
X is distributed uniformly from 0 to 2
right Chris if s is uniform from 0 to 1
you multiply by the 2 X a certain
uniformly from 0 to 2 and so the density
for X is equal to this
and it's now half as tall because
probably density functions need to
integrate to one right so this is a
uniform from zero to two
probably density function and so the
correct formula is P of X x equals 1/2
times indicator is realistic of the X
let's say equal to 2 okay and more
generally the correct formula for this
is actually this x this is the
determinant of the matrix W and in the
case of a real number the determine if I
want real number is just this absolute
value which is why we have the density
of x equals 1/2 you know that's the
absolute value of the determinant of W x
times y times indicator where there are
two times s is within 0 0 to 1 ok
right so I guess this oh this is
indicator zero less than 1/2 okay so
this is an illustration showing why this
is the right way with the determinant of
W most value here as the as a way to
compute its identity of X and don't you
familiar with determinants and
determinants is the function you can
call your numpy to compute but also the
intuition of deterministic measures how
much it stretches out a local whopping
and so you need to sort of divide by the
determinant of a or multiply by
determinant of W in order to make sure
these distributions don't normalizes the
one right so that's where that comes
from
so we're nearly done
just one more decision and then we can
derive a maximum likelihood estimation
to derive a mess with likely estimate of
this of the parameters the last thing we
need to do is choose the density of what
you know speakers voices sound like and
as I said just now what we are going to
do is choose a non Gaussian distribution
right and so well f of S is equal to the
chance of this person's voice right
random variable s being less than
certain value and we need a smooth
function that goes between you know 0
and 1 right we need a smooth function
that has Davey that shake and so well
what functions we know that they be that
shape let's take the sigmoid function
and it turns out this world this will
work ok there are many choices that
actually work fine it turns out that if
you choose the sigmoid function to be
the CDF then if you look at the PDF this
induces if you take the derivative this
right so take P of x equals the
derivative
CEDIA it turns out that if this is the
Gaussian then the PDF that this choice
induces is something with fatter tails
by which I mean that it goes to zero you
know so Gaussian density goes to zero
very quickly right it's like e to the
negative x squared the Gaussian is a
square in the exponent of the density
and it turns out that this because the
density taken by compute derivative a
sigmoid it goes to zero more slowly and
this captures human voice and many
natural phenomena better than the
Gaussian density because there are
larger number of extreme outliers there
are more than one or two standard
deviations away but they're actually
multiple distributions that work you
could have used a double double
exponential distribution so this is an
exponential distribution exponential
then see if you take a symmetric go to
side the explanation that's the PIA best
they'll also work quite well for ICA but
I think early history of ICA you know
researchers I think of them might have
been Terry Sadowski download the softest
if you just needed a function with these
properties and you picked the sigmoid
and plugged it in and it works just fine
it's been a good enough default that tom
is still it's still widely use right but
but but but they've used this double
side the exponential sometimes also
called the laplacian distribution this
works fine as well as a choice of P of s
so the final step the density of s is
equal to the product of the lessee soap
rather from I equals 1 through your n
sources of the probability of each of
the speakers emitting that sound right
because the N speakers are speaking
independently right
wait say that again
oh yes you're right sorry about that yes
this should be sorry yes this should
have been up here right go from a CD f
sub-p di by taking derivatives
oh cool
so um s is the vector of all you know
two speakers are all five speakers
voices at one moment in time so the
density of s right s is in RN is the
product of the individual speakers
probabilities and this is the key
assumption of ICA that you know your two
speakers or your five speakers are
having independent conversations and so
at every moment in time they choose
independently of each other what sound
teammate and so using the formulas you
worked out just now the density of X is
equal to well as we did the density of W
x times the determinant of W so and this
is equal to
Oh in this notation WI transpose X this
is um right because WI is the I've row
of the matrix W and so you know I guess
s SJ is equal to W J transpose X right
so you take a corresponding row and
multiply it by X to get the
corresponding source actually sorry I
think that's right yeah let me use J
there okay and so um this writes out so
this shows what is the density of X
expressed as a function of P of s which
have assumed which affects as a CDF of
the sigmoid as a as the derivative of
the sigmoid and as a function of the
parameter W right so this is a model
that given a setting of the parameters W
which square matrix allows us to write
down what's the density of banks
so the final step is we could use
maximum likelihood estimation to
estimate the parameters W so the log
likelihood of W is equal to sum over the
training examples of log and you can use
the cost agree in the sense take the
derivative of W respective along
likelihood and it turns out this is
derived a lecture notes I'll just write
it out here
I hope I got that right yeah okay right
and it turns out that if you use this
formula don't don't worry about the form
for derivatives the full derivations
give a legend else but it turns out that
if you use the derivative of the log
likelihood with respect to parameter
matrix W and use stochastic gradient a
sense to maximize the log likelihood run
this for a while then you can get ICA to
find they're pretty good matrix W for
unmixing the sources okay so just to
recap the whole algorithm right you
would have a training set of x1 up
through XM where each of your training
examples is the microphone recordings at
one moment in time and so the time goes
from 1 through m what you do is
initialize the matrix W say randomly and
use gradient descent with this formula
for the derivative in order to maximize
the log likelihood of the data and after
a gradient ascent converges you then
have a matrix W and you can then recover
the sources as s equals W of X and then
now we have the sources you can take say
s1 1 through s 1m and play that through
your you know laptop speaker in order to
see what source 1 sounds like so that's
how you would take you know
overlapping voices and try to unmixed up
a wise choice the save point now
rotation America
boy how to visualize that try plotting
it in numpy matplotlib I guess if you
plot the contours of the day so it turns
out that if this is s 1 and s 2 what you
do not want is a density whose contours
look like that haven't done this for a
while I believe if you take this
distribution the contours will look like
that it's been a while since I hope that
this but I think it'll look like that so
this is not rotations in magic do you
know this laplacian yeah ok yeah oh yes
the pasta he looks like that I think
sigmoid looks a bit like that too yeah
talk to this even right Paul's on Piazza
if one of you positive because you can
see I haven't done ever louder
oh why don't you interpret differently
along that actually yes the law should
be like this I think oh sorry
G is the sigmoid function yes so Jia Zi
sure what's the yeah what's the closest
nonlinear extension of this I don't we
don't have great answer to that right
now frankly so a bunch of people
including you know my former students
and me have done research to try to
extend this to nonlinear versions and
there's some stuff that kind of works
but I don't think there's like a
tried-and-true algorithm that I'm ready
to say this is the right way to do it
yeah actually maybe I should I can say a
little bit more about other people
interesting well yeah yeah yeah let me
let me try there
all right let's see
so so for several several years ago and
and so kind of ongoing there's been
research some done by my collaboration
me some time my others aren't trying to
build nonlinear versions of ICA and so
some of you might have seen this
slightly infamous Google Katz result
right so it doesn't want to leave the
Google brain project one of the first
parts if you did this a few years ago
now where we trained in your network on
was it many many hours of YouTube videos
and eventually it learned to detect cats
because apparently there are a lot of
cats and YouTube videos and so it turns
out that the algorithm we used was a was
sparse coding which is actually very
closely related to ICA and so this rough
algorithm was attempting to build a
nonlinear version of ICA where you train
one version once trained train one layer
of sparse coding let's say to extract
low-level features and then recursively
apply this on top to learn not just edge
detectors but object part detectors and
then eventually you know the somewhat
infamous two somewhat infamous google
cat but I think that this is actually
still ongoing research I think the most
interesting research some of the most
interesting research has been on
hierarchical versions of sparse coding
in sparse coding it's a different
algorithm that turns out to be very
closely related to ICA and then you can
show that they're optimizing for very
similar things so if I say sparse coding
is very similar ICA but there are
hierarchical versions of this they tried
to turn this as a multi-layer neural
network and it kind of works wherever
that show can learn there's new features
but what happened was a supervised
learning there and really took off in
the whole world shifted Walters
attention to supervised learning and
building deep supervised learning in
your own networks and so the hierarchal
sparse coding running I see over and
over to learn nonlinear versions there's
there's pretty less attention from
research on that on that topic then it
then it really deserves so maybe you
maybe someone in a costly go back and do
more research on that I still think is a
promising area
all right um so let me wrap up with some
ICA examples so there's actually a
former ta from the class Katie Chang and
so it turns out that ICS routinely used
to clean up
EEG data today so what's an EEG
right place many electrodes on your
scalp to measure little electrical
recordings on the surface of your scalp
so you know what does human brain do
right human brain your neurons in your
brain right now
fire generated little pulses of
electricity and if you place electrode
on your scalp you can get a very weak
measurement of the of the voltage of the
electrical activity in a you know at a
certain point in your scalp so the
analogy to oh excuse me what's wrong
alright so the analogy to the cocktail
of Hardy problem the overlapping
speakers voices is that you know your
your brain does a lot of things at the
same time right your brain helps
regulate your heartbeat part of your
brain does that and now the part of your
brain you know makes your eyes blink
every now and then another part of your
brain probably brain is also responsible
making sure that you breathe and then
part of your brain is responsible
thinking about machine learning and
stuff like that right so so your brain
actually handles memories didn't ask at
the same time and as your brain sorry
else not sure what's wrong with this
okay and as your brain carries out these
different tasks in parallel different
parts of your brain generate different
electrical impulses so I think of there
as imagine that you have a you know
cocktail party in your head right so
many overlapping voices so this is now
voices in your head bad but one one one
part of your brain is saying alright hot
go and be hot go and beat harder and
beaten and not my brains I hate breathe
in and breathe out breathe in and
breathe out now if I were in a zoo you
know what's wrong with this PowerPoint
right um and what's each electrode on
the surface of your scalp does is it
measures an overlapping combination of
all of these voices because the
different positive brain are sending
these electric impulses they add up and
so any one point on the surface of your
brain reflects a sum or a mixture really
a sum of these different voices of these
different things your brain is doing and
so if you just just zooming into the EEG
plot each line is the voltage measured
at a single electrode right on say your
scalp and these signals are quite
correlated you see that when there's a
massive voice in your brain shouting you
know like right beat your heart or blink
your eyes that signal can go through all
of the different electrodes which is why
you can see these artifacts are affected
in all of these electrodes all right
turns out a pretty good way to clean up
this data is to take all of these time
series
pretty-pretty exactly as we learned
about it with the ISEE algorithm and
separate out into the independent
components and so it turns out in this
example there are two components
corresponding to driving the heartbeat
that's actually the eye blink component
and so one way to clean up this data
sorry I should really wonder what's
wrong with this all right let me try
something
all right
if you write says hi Peters I blink and
alright and if you run I see a and then
remove out I have a person say oh that's
happy that's I blink and remove subtract
out those components then you can end up
with a much more cleaned up
eg signal which you can then use for
downstream processing sorry overpass
there is a lot of research on your
chicken eg reading to try to guess at
the high level what you're thinking
right it turns out that if you train a
trainer trainer you know supervised
learning algorithm to try to decide are
you thinking of a noun or a verb or you
thinking of something edible or are you
thinking of something any other boat
there's been very interesting research
trying to use EEG to figure out just in
a very coarse level no not quite my
reading every thought you are thinking
but that that can we categorize very
coarse level thoughts like are you
thinking of a person or you think of an
object then you can actually do that to
some extent using EQ meeting it's been
cleaning up the data to get really I
blink the heartbeat artifacts is a very
useful pre-processing step to get
cleaner data to feed into the learning
algorithm to try to figure out try to
categorize you know some coarse cavity
of what you're thinking okay and then
more research it turns out that what
kind of I mentioned that Google can't
thing just now it turns out that if you
train I see a font is messed up if you
train I see a on natural images I see a
will say that the natural independent
components of natural images are these
edges and as in that you know when you
see a little image patch in the world we
see you know look somewhere in there one
looked just a tiny little piece of the
image right like 10 pixels by 10 pixels
and if you take that data and model as
ICA I say we'll say that the world is
made up of edges or made up of patches
like these and that the way you end up
with images in the world is by each of
these patches
you know independently saying is there
reservations or horizontal insurers
is there this type of light on the left
dark on the right is that this type of
lighter on top doctor the bottom and so
on and it's by adding all of these
voices there you get a typical image
passionate world so there are there
interesting theories in neuroscience
about whether this is how you know the
human brain learns to see as well so so
very very same work on them I see and
sparse coding to try to use these
mechanisms to explain how you know the
human brain tries to explain it tries to
learn to perceive images for example
okay so all right so that's it for um
the algorithms of ICA justify no
comments I think on Mondays someone asks
do the number of speakers the number of
microphones need to be equal so it turns
out that if the number of microphones is
larger than the number of speakers
that's actually fine right if you're the
number of microphones large number of
speakers then if you run ICA or a
slightly modified version of it you find
that some of the speakers are just
silent speakers and so you know if you
have ten microphones and five speakers
if you run this algorithm on ten
microphones you can find that well maybe
five of the sources are just silent or
there ways to just now model those five
sources as well right if you think that
they're just some sources of silence so
so this so slightly modified version of
this works quite well if the number of
speakers is larger than the number of
microphones if the excuse me the number
of microphones is lodged in the Armagh
speakers this works quite well if the
number of microphones is smaller than
the number of speakers then that's still
very much a cutting-edge research
problem so so for example if you have
two speakers and one microphone it turns
out that if you have one male and one
female speaker so one relatively high
patient one much lower pitch then you
can sometimes have some algorithms that
separate out two voices with one
microphone but it doesn't work that
reliably is a little bit finicky but
there have been research papers
published showing that you know you
could make a reasonable attempt at
separating out two voices with my one
microphone though the pitches are quite
different such as is one male one female
voice but separating out two male voices
or two female voices is still very hard
and then there's ongoing research in in
those settings so that's ICA and I guess
you get to play more of it in your
homework problem as well okay any last
questions about ICA
oh wait sorry it would be Jose yeah so
um I think actually go through a lot of
math it just breaks down I think because
there you can have two independent
sources but W is now no longer a square
matrix right it'll be uh what is it
so I write so is that X is equal to a s
right and so if X is a real number and s
was two-dimensional so I guess this
would be um a would be two by one s
would be a would be 2 by 1 SOT - Suzi a
would be 1 by 2 and s would be a 2 by 1
and this is 1 by 1 then you know ain't
inverse kind of doesn't exist right so
you need to come over way to form the
mass molecular model and where you have
one microphone it's just how do you
separate out to overlapping voices so it
takes much higher level knowledge yeah
to separate out two voices
oh I see right let's see so right so if
you don't know how many speakers there
are you have all these microphones where
you about the number of electrodes you
have is fixed so that's just a data set
and it turns out that if you run ICA
where the large numbers speakers you
find them in the speakers are silent
there are also some versions of ICA that
you so if you think that there are let's
see why
no smells worse on this but it turns out
that um if you think that there is a
relatively small number of speakers then
you don't need to explicitly model all
the speakers instead what you would
model so again suppose sense of Max or
likely estimation problem let's say
that's X is in our 10 right Co 10
recordings but you suspect that you're
near 5 speakers then in this case I
guess the matrix a would be um what is
it was it be 10 by 5 is it right to mix
the five sources into 10 speakers and
you could for me the maximum likelihood
estimation problem assuming the
existence of only 5 speakers without
modeling a lot of speakers and then
finding later that they're all silent so
if your formula so if you parameterize
model like this using a instead of W
then can form their maximum likelihood
estimation problem where you just assume
that they're 5 speakers and s is
generated by five speakers mixing
through a linear thing plus the noise
oh I see sure right how do you know if
you have how do you know how this
because you have so I think it's one of
those things a little bit like k-means I
guess where you try it and see what
works and if you find that the first
view you know speakers will capture
mostly variance you find the digital
speakers are quite silent and they're
quite small that you could just cut off
at that time I don't want to go too much
into the different numbers of speakers
and and and microphones I see a verbose
let me just take a couple of questions
only one question yeah is it oh do you
ever see my parent of you um I'm sure
you can is not usually done in this
version of the algorithm but I would not
be surprised if there are some other
versions where you do I've not seen that
about myself actually all right cool
good um so
all right
all right so that wraps up our chapter
on unsupervised learning right so you
learned about yes k-means clustering the
Yemm algorithm for mixture of gaussians
really makes your gaseous model factor
analysis model and also PCA and then you
know today the ica independent
components analysis algorithm and all of
these were the algorithms that could
take as input an unlabeled training set
just the excise and no labels and we
find various interesting structures in
the data such as clusters or subspaces
or in the case of ICA the voices of you
and the speakers and you implement ICA
and play about yourself in the homework
problem well you get to separate out
many five overlapping voices the loss of
the four major topics well cover in this
verse we Thomas two eyes learning kind
of advice machine learning on two eyes
learning and the fourth and the final
major topics we cover in this class will
be a reinforcement learning so to
motivate reinforcement learning let's
say you want to have a computer learn to
fly a helicopter right I think I showed
some of the videos that are in the first
lecture and so I'll just skip that here
but it turns out that if you are at
every point in time given the position
of a helicopter call the state of a
helicopter and you also take an action
on how to move the control sticks you
know to make the helicopter fly in a
certian trajectory it turns out that
it's very difficult to know what's the
one right answer for how to move the
control sticks of a helicopter right so
if you don't have a mapping from x to y
because you can't quite specify the one
true way to fly a helicopter it's hard
to use supervised learning
and what the enforcement learning does
is is is it is an algorithm that doesn't
ask you to tell it the right answer at
every step it doesn't ask you to tell it
exactly what's the one true way to move
the controls of a helicopter at any
moment in time instead your
responsibility as a designer a machine
or an engineer or an engineer is to
specify reward function that just tells
the helicopter when it's flying well and
when it's lying poorly so your job as a
designer is to write a cost function or
reward function that gives the
helicopter a high reward whenever it's
doing well flying accurately find reject
you want sue and gives the helicopter a
large negative reward whenever it
crashes with or something bad then I
think I think you know think of this
like training a doll right when do you
say good dog when you say bad dog and
the dog figures out when to do more the
good dog things and your job is not to
tell the dog you know well you can't
actually talk to the dog and tell what
to do I guess that doesn't work but you
can tell a good dog and bad dog and
hopefully their instruments positive
negative was how to do more of the good
things another example let's say you
want to write their program to play
chess or I guess most know somewhat
famously and arguably somewhat slightly
over height go alpha go right so it's
very difficult to know in given a
certain chess board position or checkers
or go for position what is the one true
move what's the one best move so it's
very difficult to formulate you know
playing chess as a supervised learning
problem and instead the mechanisms used
to play chess are much more like
reinforcement learning where you can let
your program play chess or go or
whatever and whenever it wins you go oh
good computer and when it loses you go
oh bad computer so that's a reward
function and learning algorithms job is
to figure out by itself how to get more
of the positive rewards right and
actually common rewards for learning to
play chess or checkers or fellow go is a
plus reward of plus one for win
- one for Luzon zero for a time say
ready a chest pain program this be a
common choice reward where R is the
reward function and s is the state okay
and I will go into the notation in a
little bit and so as you can imagine
giving only this type of information to
their chest pain program it places much
more burden on the program to figure out
what to do in fact one of the challenges
of reinforcement learning is so just
call the reward that's called the state
and the state means on the status of the
chess board where are the pieces on a
chess board or the status of the
helicopter where exactly is a helicopter
and are you the right side up or upside
down and where are you right and it
turns out one of the challenges one of
the things that makes them reinforce the
learning Hart is the credit assignment
problem and that means that if your
program is playing a game of chess and
let's say it loses on move 50 you know
so plays a game and then I'll move 50
right it's checkmate and then loses his
opponent so gets a reward a negative one
but how can the program actually figure
out what it did well and what it did
poorly right if you lose a game and move
50 it might be that the program made a
really bad move made a blunder and move
20 and then you know but they just hope
another 30 moves before his fates were
sealed right so in the game of chess we
made a bad mistake early on you can
still take many many games there are
many many moves in the game of chess
before before the final outcome of
losing or winning or losing this reached
or in a and a another it turns out that
so if you are trying to build a
self-driving car if ever car crashes
rain chances are the thing the car was
doing right before it crashes was break
but it's not breaking that causes a
crash it's pretty something else I
called it many many seconds ago then
- the bad outcome so there's a bad
outcome how does the algorithm know of
all the things that did before how does
it know whether it did well which you
should do more of and one it did poorly
which you should do less of and
conversely if that's a good outcome
you're like a wins a game of chess well
how do you know what you did well right
so that's called the credit assignment
problem which is when your algorithm
gets some reward how do you actually
figure out what you did what you did
poorly so you know what to do more of
and what to do less up right so as we
develop reinforcement learning
algorithms will see that the algorithms
we use have to at least indirectly try
to solve the credit assignment problem
okay so um reinforcement learning
problems like play chess of AI
helicopters or you know building these
there's robots is modeled using the MDP
or the Markov decision process
and this is a way this is a notation in
the formulism but modeling how the world
works and then reinforcement learning
algorithms will solve problems using
this formula zhim so what is an MDP sin
MDP is a five tuple and let me explain
what each of these are so s there's a
set of states so for example in chess
this would be the set of all possible
chess positions or in flying a
helicopter this would be the set of all
the possible positions and orientations
and velocities of your helicopter a is
the set of actions where in the
helicopter this would be all the
positions you could move your control
sticks or in Chester's be all the moves
you could make you know in a in a game
of chess
P subscript s a is is a state transition
probabilities and so we'll see later
this state transition probably is tell
you if you take a certain action a and a
certain state s once the chance of you
ending up at a particular different
state s prime our gamma is the discount
factor as number between 0 and 1
don't worry about this for now we'll
come back to this in a minute and R is
that all-important reward function so
in order to develop a reinforcement
learning algorithm I'm going to use as a
running example a simplified MDP that we
can draw on the whiteboard right so
helicopters in chess and go and so on
they're really complicated MDP so just
to illustrate the algorithms I'm going
to use a simpler MVP and this is an
example we drawn from the textbook
Russell and Norvig then we'll use imply
MVP in which you have a robot navigating
this simple maze and there's an obstacle
so this is a grid world icy robot you
know and it's navigating this very
simple maze and this is a pillar or this
is a wall so you can't walk into that
wall and let me just use indexing on the
states as follows so this MDP let's
let's go through the five tempo and talk
about what the the each of the five
things are so this MVP has eleven states
corresponding to the eleven possible
positions that the robot could be in
right each of these banks square so the
eleven possible states and the actions
are north south east and west
right you can come on your robot to move
in any of these directions and I don't
know if you're working robots before you
know that um when you come on the robot
you know head straight it doesn't always
go exactly straight sometimes the wheel
slip it veers of a slight angle and so
in this simplified example we're going
to model it as that if you command the
robot to go north from a certain state
that there's a 0.8 percent chance
they'll successfully go where you told
it to and there's zero point one chance
that they'll accidentally if you're off
to the left for a student if you're off
to the right
okay if you are working on row robots
right what's a lot of robots it is
actually important to model the noisy
dynamics of a robot real slipping so
your orientation being slightly off now
in a real robot you'd have a much bigger
stage space than the eleven states right
so so this is simplified so this is not
a realistic model for how robots
actually slip but because we're using
such a small state space I think just
for illustration purposes as well well
we'll use this and so for example the
state transition probably so specified
is you say that every under state 3 1 so
the state 3 comma 1 and you command it
to go north that the chance of getting
to the state 3 2 is 0.8 and the chance
are getting to the States for 10.1
Charles again 2 to 1 is 0.1 and the
chance of getting to other states is
like 3 3 and other states is equal to 0
ok so the state transition probabilities
would capture that if you here in
surgical north as the whole point a
chance of getting here 0.1 chance again
here 0.1 chance of getting here and you
know point Oh a chance of right hopping
to steps
oh it's implement a PE example we'll
just assume that the robot you know hits
a wall it just bounces off the wall and
stays where it is
so if you told us to go 'yes it slips
off it just bounced off the wall and
stay exactly where this now let's
specify the reward function we'll come
back to discount factor later but let's
say you want the robot to navigate to
this cell in the upper right hand corner
and so to incentivize the reward
incentivize the robot to get to this
square you know that's the prize
Saguna knees let's put a +1 reward there
and let's say you really don't want the
robot to go to this cell they could put
a negative one or what there right so
the way you specify the toss for a robot
to do is in designing the reward
function
so in our example I'm just copied out of
the game plus one minus one we have that
the reward at the cell for three is plus
one and the reward at the cell for 2 is
minus one and then you know if you want
the robot to get to the plus one rewards
cell as quickly as possible then again
there there are many ways of designing
reward functions but one common choice
would be to put a negative penalty a
very small negative penalty right such
as a set of rewards a negative 0.02 for
all other states and the effect of a
small negative reward like this is to
charge it right every every step it is
just loitering around so charge a little
bit for using electricity and wandering
around because this incentivizes a robot
to hurry up and get to the plus one
reward right so you give a small penalty
you know loitering and wasting
electricity
so this is how an MDP works your robot
wakes up at some state as zero at time
zero because you turn on the robot and
the robot says oh I'm at this state
and based on what state it is in it will
get to choose some action a zero so
decides I want to go north south east or
west let's choose some action based on
the action the consequence of the choice
is it will get to some state s1 to stay
that the next time step which is
distributed according to the state
transition probability is governed by
the previous state and the action and
chose so develop what actually chose is
there's different chances of moving
north south east or west now that is an
s-1 it then has to choose a new action
a1 and as a consequence of the action a1
it will get to some new state s2 which
is governed by the state transition
probabilities you know s 1 a1 and so on
okay and then the robot just keeps on
running
and so the robot will go through a
sequence of states s0 s1 s2 and so on
depending on the choices it receives
defend the actions it chooses and the
total payoff is written as follows with
one more detail is that term gamma so
think of gamma as a number like 0.99 so
gamma is usually chosen to be just
slightly less than one and what the so
the total payoff is the sum of rewards
or more technically as a sum of
discounted rewards and what this does is
it adds up all the rewards that the
robot receives over time but the further
reward is into the future you know the
smaller the gammas ^ time that that
reward is x okay so anyway what'd you
get this time one you get all of that
every one you get at time - its x point
99 Roy gets thanks that this one point
99 squared or not a cube and so on and
so what the discount factor does is it
has the effect of giving a smaller way
to rewards in the distant future and
this means that this encourages the
robot to also get the positive rewards
faster or postpone the negative rewards
right and so in financial applications
the discount factor has one as has a
natural interpretation as the time value
of money because if you have a dollar
today you know you're better off having
a dollar today they're having a year $1
year from now right because you put the
dollar in the bank and
interests for a year on your dollar and
so dollars they're strictly rather than
thought in the future
and conversely having to pay $100 or
having to pay one dollar a year from now
is also better than having to pay a
dollar today right because if you could
you know save your money and earn inches
and then issue a payment to someone else
a year from now rather than now then
you're actually slightly wealthier and
so and so the gamma and financial
applications as an interpretation as the
time value of money
oh it's the interest rate I guess and
but but but more generally even for
non-financial applications most of our
most there are some financial
applications our enforcement but lots of
non fan traffic as well this mechanism
of using a discount factor has the
effect of encouraging the system to get
to the positive was as quickly as
possible but then also conversely to try
to push the negative rewards as founds
in the future as possible right oh and I
think to be pragmatic there are two
reasons why people use gamma the story I
just told time value of money
your friends'll sponsor was postponed
that was that's that's the story you
tend to people you tend to hear people
say in terms of why we have a discount
factor the other reason where the
discount factor is actually much more
pragmatic one which is that lovely
reinforcement learning algorithms you
see they converge much faster or they
work much better if you're willing to
have a discount factor right so it turns
out that if gamma is is equal to 1 if
gamma is not strictly less than 1 it's
much harder or they're there many
ripples to learning algorithms that may
not converge you as much how the croutha
conversions of no may not converse which
isn't a pragmatic thing this makes the
job much easier for your algorithms now
I see sorry you're shaking your heads in
this disapproval all right
yeah yeah yes yeah that's a good point
yes so one of the things if there's no
camera is that the reward summer was you
know could be can increase or decrease
of our balance so by having gammer
discount easier the total payoff is a
finite value whereas the boundary value
so that that's one of the parts they go
into some of the proofs or something
reasons behind why rate for so many
avenues conversion yeah okay so the go
of reinforcement learning is to choose
actions over time to maximize the
expected total payoff
and in particular what most
reinforcement learning algorithms will
come up with is a policy that maps from
States to actions right so the output of
most reinforcement learning algorithms
will be a policy or controller in the
our world we tend to use the term policy
but policy just means controller there
maps of states actions so it turns out
that for the MDP that we have right it
turns out that this is the optimal
policy
so for example I want you to take this
example just this cell here to sell over
here
this policy is saying PI apply to the
state 3 1 as equal to West and that so
so it separately worked out what is the
optimal policy and this turns out to be
also a policy in the sense that if you
we say execute this policy so the
executors policy means that whenever you
in the state s take the action given by
PI of s so that's what it means to
execute a certain policy and it turns
out that this policy was I worked out
separately right offline you know in my
laptop that this is the optimal policy
for this MVP and it turns out that if
you execute this policy meaning whenever
a certain state you know take the action
indicated by the arrow that this is the
policy that will maximize the expected
total payoff okay and the problem in
reinforcement learning is given a
definition for an MDP or given a problem
suppose the problem is an MDP figure out
what's the set of states with set of
actions one of the state transition
probabilities specify a discount factor
a specified reward function and then to
a reinforcer learning algorithm find the
policy PI that maximizes expected payoff
and then when you want your robot to act
or when you want your chess playing
program to act whenever you're in
something s take the action given by PI
of s and hopefully this will result in a
robot that you know efficiently
navigates to the +1 state
so turns out that MVPs are quite good at
making fine distinction so one example
is actually not totally obvious whether
here you're better off going off or
going west right and it turns out that
there is a trade off if you go Wes here
then you know you're gonna take a longer
route to get to the plus one so you take
longer the plus one is discounted more
heavily you're taking these penalties
along the way excuse me
but on the flip side if you were to try
to go north you could try to get there
faster but on this that there's a 0.1%
chance that you accidentally slip off to
the minus one state so so what is the
optimal action right it's actually quite
hard to just look at it with your eyes
and make a decision but it turns out
that if you solve for the optimal set of
actions and does MDP you in this example
is they just take longer and safer route
the sense of why cycles and policies so
if the optimal set of actions is the
cycle around then it should find out I
mean for example if they're only
penalties everywhere and she's just go
and run in a circle you know then then
the algorithm watch she choose to do
that but in this case you want to get to
the plus one as quickly as possible
and so what we'll see is one question
wait so alright sure sorry so testing
checkers and go and so on they're a
little more complication is you take a
move so actually to refine the
description of chess what happens in
playing chess is the state status your
board right says your move so you see a
board that's the state and so you make a
move and then the opponent makes a move
and then that's the new state so the
state is when you and your opponent both
make take turns then it's cut back to
you right and because you don't know
exactly what your opponent will do there
is a probably distribution over if I
make a move or what's the other person
gonna do yeah right oh they're probably
sighs I'm very no two point eight point
one point one where does that come from
so we'll talk about that later
in some applications does this learn so
if you build a robot you might not know
is it point eight point one point one or
you know point seven point one five
point one five so it's quite common to
use data to learn those state transition
probabilities as well well we'll see a
specific example that into it okay so
alright so where we are just to
summarize this is how you formulate a
problem as an MDP and then the the job
reinforcing learning algorithm is ready
to go from there MDP to telling you what
is a good policy okay
so let's break and then Oh have a good
Thanksgiving everyone
won't see you for like a week and half
enjoy yourselves and we'll reconvene
after Thanksgiving with